[Musica]
allora ragazzi una nuova puntata 2
episodio di among us coi ragazzi siamo
krumm eight con l'albero per cento
dell'area classe cielo ho sentito un po
fesr reo secondo lei perché ha parlato
ha parlato la seguo la segue per sé e
per sé per sé la vedo che fare
eccola non c'è una tasca qui non si c'è
una tasca ora spetta a noi per non
essere ragazzi siamo in una mappa lohan
tanto non lo facciamo mai quest'anno
perché non è nuova cioè da sempre però
dai facciamo sempre l'altra ma
finalmente facciamo una mappa nuova
allora meglio vanno le stesse stata ski
di fare quindi per sé non può essere
perché c'è le mie stesse tasche o siamo
sincronizzati o non lo so tanto in
genere morì sempre qualcuno dei primi
tot secondi quindi secondo me è già
morto qualcuno iamm maledizione marcia
trovato loco ok ma anche tu non lo
vedevi l'ora
io sono entrato ieri non lo so ho visto
dei bianco però non ho visto che però
non ho visto il corpo sinceramente ho
visto solo marcia in questo report non
riuscivo il corpo infatti blu che per
prima dov'era i volti nascosti da agenti
la 206 immaginette qua pesante vediamo
se qualcuno ammazza qualcuno vedo che
c'è gente che va su io seguo gente la
nato è uscito di collina se c'è qualche
colpo non c'è marzio il suo admin check
che palle
secondo me fare non è io rimango vicino
appena i ragazzi perché bene sono
convinto che non si sa quando poi ci
ricorda di queste cagate di sì o di
solito muoio io e capisci che non sono
io e rimani vicino a me per favore
rimaniamo vicini che abbiamo capito che
uno non è l'altro live
siamo un po di tattica questo gioco
maledetto si vede resi ha fissato le
cucine march che è uscito dalla moto la
march è uscita dalla botola mar
secondo me è uscita dalla bocca io non
so se continui
se continuo ad avere sfighe quindi
riferimenti sbagliati ma mi sembra che
tu sia uscita da volta la marcia io no e
sono in office in quel momento perché
quando sei esami incrociati dalla band
poi magari preferita è la missione
esattamente lì sopra e non lo so cos'e
gianna raga difficilissimo
mamma mia è troppo difficile ma dai
ragazzi non si vede neanche se uno è
l'imposta non lo è e non lo può essere
franci cosa secondo me lega si vede
troppo che fa bovino i movimenti strani
no forse no se mi sbaglio sai allora
veramente march ma contempo striscione
scusa avremmo già perso a quest ora però
quindi non abbiamo perso quindi ora
abbiamo votato fuori veramente oppure no
oppure niente poi avremo quindi è vera
veramente lui perché se lo avremmo perso
questo ora chi cacchio ad altro caso
sono e marci io voterei marci
vediamo se c'è veramente una tasca da
palestra tra botola perché magari mi ha
detto una cagata
ma non c'è nessuna tasche la palestra ma
non c'è una task qui non lo so essere
morte però siamo concordi che è rimasto
un impostore solo chi è stato franci
koso davanti a me a chi lato fiere io a
stato freddissimo e c'era march sopra il
cadavere dai raga ottima io ti ho fatto
buttare fuori nappa vtt ricordo solo
veramente nata alla fine di essi era
veramente non è vero
questo è vero ma ci guarda se viene
fregato così io in titolo il video
margini ha [ __ ] travolta in un video
vediamo nessuno mi caga nessuno mi parlò
solido manca una sola
va bene la march mi ha [ __ ] tre volte
in un video kay crew mentone o vediamo
assist a partita riesco a differenziarmi
ragazzi dagli altri in qualche modo tipo
morendo no fix lights raga peak site
adesso no senza se sono morti se per
caso lui è imposto reso noto quindi
questo posto tutto prosegue faccio prima
non era lui
ok nico è veramente pulito ci saremmo
stati a vicenda con una bene cioè non si
vedeva niente fix lights veramente fare
mostra morti a questo era tutti e due io
lui e quindi lui dovrebbe essere pulito
o se l'è giocata estremamente bene per
la ii b
secondo me potrebbe essere fair e
scommettiamo che per mi ci gioco guarda
qualsiasi ff questa volta è per sé e non
so se march ma non credo però fare
sicuro ma chi è che sta facendo le luci
signori non c'è bisogna mai non c'è
bisogno di nulla e votate tutti loco
perché perché ho visto tutti in
decontaminazione tranne loco che è
infatti già varato in modo molto strana
communication
al momento le luci chi lettina
strategica è poi scappato da ragazzi
facciamolo fuori si prepara la gara noi
da ricky si sa siamo tutti attaccati
quindi per l'impostore veramente in un
casinò vincere il problema è che non
vedo march da un'ora e mezza non vedo
march da un'ora e mezza dove cacchio è
march dai siamo siamo tutti appiccicati
come pali postale addormenta un dai
ragazzi abbiamo scelti insieme tutti
insieme tutti insieme
veloci veloci tutti insieme sono un
gioco da ragazzi certo non siamo
attaccati quel casino
dobbiamo stare attaccati se non ci
scappano per forza ok 4 tempo 14 secondi
non ce la faremo mai
mamma mia è stato quello più lontano
ok marxista qua e martis marce ma mi
sembra di aver visto il giallo sincero
forse il colpo d'occhio errato e non
saprei allora c'era marchi allora
provato una ragazzo provato di un
secondo di un secondo salone a destra mi
barcameno la task manager haga di un
secondo non vince non vincevo dire una
cosa che ti attacca pianificati quella
mostra le ventole cattivoni ma
realistico non sapevo che fare
io ho finalmente sei stati impostore
finalmente
[Musica]